well good morning this is a day I've
been looking forward to for a long time
a lot of Seir have been talking over the
months ahead trying to make sure that we
get everyone to show up and and do
absolutely the best they can for
vaccination a little word when we were
driving in this morning to see a lot of
protesters out there on the street and I
thought geez what what could they say
about vaccines well in fact what they
were saying is they love vaccines and
they were encouraging us all here to
make this support and so organizations
that have gathered that positive energy
and support for this like one and save
the children and it's fantastic to see
we've heard from some great speakers
this morning people who are leading the
way the UK in terms of making increases
Norway is the the most generous donor
and you'll hear from others later who
are really pushing hard to come up with
the resources to save these children
these are tough budget times and so I
know it it takes a lot but we're gonna
see the the value of that in terms of
what gobby's able to achieve this
vaccine work is the biggest program for
the Gates Foundation and that's because
it is so impactful
it's incredible value it utterly changes
the country to have the newest vaccines
saving children's lives and equally
important avoiding children getting sick
so much that they never fully developed
on their mental and physical capacities
this actually goes back to the very
beginning of our foundation my wife in
London and I found out about a disease
called rotavirus that was killing a half
million children a year and we said this
is stunning we've never heard of it
and we looked into how much work was
being done to solve this disease to get
a vaccine out to the poorest countries
and we found that there was very little
and so we knew that we'd found the cause
that we could take all the resources we
were lucky enough to have and give them
back to the world in an impactful way
and so it's a wonderful milestone to be
here today getting the pledges that will
make sure that every child in the world
can have that rotavirus vaccine now
gobby is a is a great investment because
it really gets into the countries and
gets these new vaccines out there in the
last decade that's been the case in the
decade ahead we have these additional
vaccines and it's been a shame that in
some cases countries have applied to
gobby but because of financial
limitations we haven't been able to
approve their applications for the new
vaccines and so when we saw that a year
ago we said we've got to rally around
and make sure that doesn't happen again
and that's why we set a very ambitious
goal for today's conference a lot of
people said don't you understand this is
a tough time to be doing this and we
said absolutely but we knew that the the
facts were on our side we also have had
great support from the vaccine
manufacturers in terms of continuing to
get the prices down and so that makes
all of this possible we also have
ambitious goals for getting vaccine
coverage up it's wonderful that it's up
at 80%
but gobby working with key partners in
particular WH o and and UNICEF can get
that even higher and so today gives us
resources that will go into that so how
do how do we look at the timeline well
going back to 2000 that's when Gavi was
first established within five years they
had gotten
hepatitis-b moth 'less influenza hip and
yellow fever out to lots and lots of
people it's now that we're gonna start
to get the last two vaccines that rich
kids take for granted the pneumococcus
and and rotavirus and over these next
five years get them out to every child
everywhere that means for the first time
ever that we have equity in vaccines
that we don't take the poorest children
who are actually the most susceptible to
these diseases and the benefit of giving
them the vaccine is the highest and yet
in the past they've been the ones who
don't get it and so it it really is in
the achievement of equity this is a very
important day in our foundation wants to
do its part and so I'm pleased to
announce to you that we're pledging an
additional billion dollars just
thank you
all right thank you
it's not everyday we give away billions
of dollars but for a cause like this
it's it's exciting to be doing it so
that'll be over the the next five years
50 million of that will be set aside for
the kind of matching that you've heard
about that the UK is it's also
encouraging and we have people like
Letitia who's already taking advantage
of that match program with the generous
gift they're giving so we think that as
a creative structure now you can look at
this gift in terms of the the money you
can look at it in terms of the 46
million children that will get these
vaccines or you can look at it at the
the 700,000 lives that will be saved or
the additional kids who because they'll
be healthy will end up contributing so
much more to the world I also think that
with the momentum we have here that it
will really spur on the great research
going on to create new vaccines we don't
yet have a malaria vaccine but there's a
lot of work great work going on we have
work going on for other diseases as well
and all the different scientists we'll
see based on the what's being pledged
today that when they have those
breakthroughs the world is willing to
step up and make sure that all the kids
who need these vaccines will get them
thank you